To make the linter most effective,
you want to have it run at
the earliest possible time.
And the earliest possible time is,
in your case,
after you press the key on your
keyboard, making a change in Sublime.
In order for this to work, you'll
need to install ESlint first via npm.
Run npm install eslint in the terminal,
and
don't forget the g option
to install it globally.
Great.
Now that you've got
eslint on your system,
you need two different Sublime plugins.
SublimeLinter is a framework
around linting, but
doesn't come with specific
language linters.
And SublimeLinter-contrib-eslint
is the wrapper code that connects
ESLint to SublimeLinter.
When you're done, restart your
editor and come back to this video.
Now look at the main.js
file in the js folder.
Notice that the linter
doesn't do anything yet.
You might be forgiven for
believing that something didn't
work during installation.
But all is fine.
It's just that ESLlint,
by default, doesn't do anything
unless you configure it.
Luckily it's simple to generate
a basic configuration.
Switch back to your terminal,
where you should still be in a sample
directory, and run eslint in it.
This will bring up this nifty prompt
that asks you a few questions,
then generates an eslintrc file for you.
If you now open that file in Sublime,
you'll notice a few style rules
from the prompts you just answered.
But the key is the extends
block at the bottom.
This tells eslint to run with
its recommended set, and
anything you add on top will
overwrite or add to it.
That's super useful as a starting point.
Here's eslint in action.
See the foo variable, the red dot
next to the line numbers, and
how Sublime highlighted it
with a red border all around.
To know which error occurred,
just click on on foo and
look at status bar at
the bottom of Sublime.
In this simple example,
it's obvious that we're missing a var.
Let's fix it.
But now foo is still red,
oh but the status changed.
We actually fixed a previous error and
are now looking at a new one.
Foo is now defined but
never used in your code.
So it's fair that ESLint
complains about it.
Let's add a return statement to
actually use foo in some way.
Here we go, just as I stop typing,
the red vanished and
thus, all errors went away.
If you open your gulpfile.js, though,
you notice a lot of red
around the require blocks,
that's because ESLint thinks
that files run in the browser.
And the browser has no require function.
We only want ESLint to turn off
no JS warnings in this file,
and luckily, you can do that.
This special type of comment works
just like a configuration, but
it's local to the current file.
Before we move on to learn how to
integrate ESLint into your build,
keep in mind that the amazing
SublimeLinter plug in also supports
dozens of other linters.
So if you'd like your CCS, HTML, or
even PHP lintered,
there's a plug in for that.
Check the notes for links on what
else you can do with SublimeLinter.